[Music]
good afternoon everybody and welcome
back to the lobby game spots weekly
hangout where we talk about video games
and everything in the world of video
games it's our first episode of the year
first of season
four if you're one of those people who
follows it closely enough uh it's
january 10th i'm mike mccarty your host
uh i'm here with peter brown hi and jake
decker how's it going
good we're gonna all three of us be
hanging out here today but before we get
into uh kind of our current events and
what's going on this week i wanted to uh
preface a few changes because the lobby
is changing um basically we are going to
start moving the show to wednesdays as
of now wednesday morning so this is kind
of part of a bigger objective we want to
get you guys more involved you as the
viewer involved in the lobby and we're
not just saying that we're not just you
know throwing around terms like audience
engagement and like stuff like that we
actually want your input we want you to
be participating more in the
conversation we want you to tell us what
you think of these games rather than us
just telling you whether you should buy
them or not so hopefully by moving it to
wednesday it'll give you more of you a
chance to play these games such as like
something new like resident evil 7
coming up for instance you know you'll
get to play it a few hours maybe beat it
and then talk to us about your thoughts
uh you'll be sending you know you can
tweet at us you can email us we'll have
you know something set up we're going to
work on that so come next week we will
uh you know we'll start doing reader
mailbags you have input for the show if
you have things you'd like us to change
we're going to try out a new studio for
at least
an episode or two see how it works we're
hoping it'll uh be a little more
streamlined it'll fit the tone of our
podcast a little more but again we want
your input so please join us in this
season of the lobby and uh have some fun
with us and help us form the show into
what you as the audience want to see and
uh we'll do the best we can to work with
you
anyway let's move on to today's episode
which will be a pretty traditional
episode of the lobby
but news was not traditional first off
pete you reviewed gravity rush 2. that
happened yeah you've been playing that
for what like a week or two now yeah put
in like
about 25 hours and you give it a nine
you liked it a lot yeah i really did
what's uh
i mean we'll dive into like that
specifically i i didn't play much
i didn't play much gravity rush one um i
was gonna try out i still haven't gotten
the chance to play two yet so i had a
lot of questions for you jake i know you
played the first one um but yeah like
hit us with it what's the overarching
like what did you enjoy about this game
so much uh well you got to keep in mind
that i definitely like played a lot of
the first game right like i ended up
reviewing the remaster so i had that
context going in which ended up being
pretty important uh to just my personal
experience because you know like this
game the first game definitely nailed
uh delivering like a very unconventional
sense of movement like games play with
flight and gravity all the time but none
really makes them the way that gravity
rush did the rest of the game around
that was kind of lacking so
one of the things that really surprised
me that i loved about gravity rush too
is that it you know the same mechanics
returned they they built upon those but
more importantly the world is just far
more dense and just bigger in general
like huge
um and so yeah scale is one thing and
like that's great uh but then also i
felt like i was able to get a lot more
out of the world just by simply
exploring it and side quests they
weren't always the best objectives to
chase but they did offer nice
interesting narratives um so you know
it's just like an all-around like a
really
really just great game and and even if
you just took it at a superficial level
the graphics and the the soundtrack are
are just amazing yeah it's gorgeous like
a cell shading on the character at least
is that kind of true for the a little
bit yeah kind of yeah it is just this
sort of like cartoonish uh render and it
definitely fits the game because it's
presented
you say episodic that brings to mind
certain aspects of episodic games but
really it's just this game is broken up
into quote-unquote episodes and and
through that and with the the visual you
know style it kind of feels like you're
playing an anime like it does feel like
you are an anime superhero and you
finish an entire season yeah um which is
pretty cool cool yeah i mean like while
you were touching on it you said like
the obviously you see a lot of series go
kind of open world whereas you know
their predecessors might not be might be
a little more linear but you did feel
that overall the structure of this game
in terms of being open world and
explorable i think you mentioned your
review that like obviously half the joy
this game just comes from moving around
this open world yeah and like the first
game definitely had the same
sensibilities it just didn't have the
scope to really you know match what
people think of when they think of open
world right i mean it was really just
one location with a few
secondary places that were detached in
the original game uh so yeah in this one
you definitely get you know a better
sense that you're part of a larger
society and it really helps that all the
people and you know things happening in
the world like sort of fill in that
picture as well because it's it's not
like just a couple npcs here and there
it's a lot of npcs and they're all going
about their own business
there's a lot of like air traffic like
air vehicles and stuff so just
in terms of being an open world it feels
you know fully realized at this stage
you're a fan of stories and video games
i like them how's this one
uh
it is good it's again i think because i
experienced the first game which left a
lot of unanswered questions i found the
story in this game to be super valuable
um there is like a new tale that is told
that is sort of about okay there's a
society where there's rich people and
there's poor people and they struggle to
kind of get along like okay that age-old
tale and that that is okay like there's
enough character in there to feel like
it's enjoyable but the huge payoff is
how the game addresses things from the
past even going you know
uh prior to the original game so acting
as a prequel as much as it is a sequel
in some ways
uh super fulfilling um you know i don't
have as many unanswered questions this
time and any that i do have
it's intentional like it seems like it's
made
on purpose would people be better off
playing the first game first in order to
fully enjoy the second game
that's a tough question the first game
is good but like
if i had to
i mean i would say play this game first
i think you'll get a lot out of it
anyway
um
[Music]
yeah
because at least mechanically this game
is there's it's more diverse so it's
more rewarding just to to play
uh story aside the story bit is what
kind of complicates that answer yeah
there's like separate movement styles
she gets right the lunar and the
uh jupiter jupiter right so lower ones
like
anti even more anti-gravity well so
i mean like her special ability normally
you're basically saying okay the center
of gravity works like this now and then
you end up basically deciding which way
is down right so you fall
uh where you want to but you end up
using like a gravity power quote unquote
in the lunar style you just equip armor
and you can still trigger your gravity
ability but you're also just made
lighter without activating that ability
so you can do things like jump really
far and high
which makes exploration feel a little
bit different because you don't have to
careen through a city or walk on the
ground you can like literally jump over
buildings which is different than flying
um
and then in battle there's you know some
things that lunar adds jupiter makes you
sort of like a tank uh you fall a lot
faster but you hit a lot harder so it's
sort of the antithesis to the lunar
style and they said the boss battles are
pretty badass in this game right yes uh
the combat is sort of
very similar between enemies and big
bosses like you're doing the same basic
things
but the presentation and the scale of
the boss fights are what are really
impressive um there's one
uh i didn't capture footage of it it
turns out but if you've ever seen akira
and you know the final scene of that
movie i've i can't think of any other
homages but this game does an homage to
that
like better than i can imagine any other
thing doing it it's really cool what is
cats deal what's your deal like what's
the premise of these
for people who don't know in a nutshell
what's what's the premise of these games
well so the the premise in the original
game was that cat didn't know who she
was she woke up in a city she had
amnesia do any of us right
i don't know i asked myself that every
day and i never have a good answer no
one ever does sorry i interrupted uh
yeah so
that last game there was you know sort
of some political stuff going on in the
society she lived in and there was this
guy named alias who was kind of egging
her on and also kind of helping things
he didn't know who she was he didn't
know who alias was
so in this game
that story is addressed but initially
what the deal is is like at the end of
the second game you didn't see it but in
the interim there was a gravity storm
you were swept up and you lost your
powers and you ended up in this like
slave camp basically
um and you have to kind of fight your
way out of that earn the trust of the
leader and you realize okay she's a
pretty good person and you have to
basically stop the rich from corrupting
government in this this new location uh
and then it builds from there but i
can't spoil anything well one thing that
sounds you've been waiting to say this
two we need uh just a show on gamespot
dedicated to you describing these
outlandish plots in the most deadpan way
as if you're describing like your
commute to work
i don't know i got on the bus
there's a couple homeless i have to turn
off to like get all these details
through the driver almost crashed it was
raining yeah but it was didn't crash it
wasn't that exciting
meanwhile yes dude named alias there's a
gravity storm while you're in a coma
typical that's like the zombie
apocalypse trope while you're like the
what is it um 28 days later and then
walking dead did it as well no this time
it's a gravity storm you wake up and
it's not zombies it's floating
oxygen
no one understands gravity don't give me
that
if you don't have her powers i feel like
that city would be a nightmare to live
in yes
yeah how do normal people get around
they're stuck on their little spot
because it's all islands everything is
like broken up in the islands but they
do have those little airships
um one of my one of the really fun
things to do in this game uh it because
you have these gravity powers so you can
like also pick up things that are around
you it's sort of what you create like a
statis stasis shield or something like
that yeah and
you can just go into the middle of a
market and just activate that thing
and people and objects and stalls and
businesses just like
fly up in the air and you can like throw
them into other things and people just
kind of pick themselves up and dust
themselves off and keep going yeah it's
the game is you know it deals with some
heavy-handed stuff but like i said in my
review like there's a silver lining to
everything sometimes that's humor it
doesn't really try to be real in all
respects just going through your footage
because i edited
just going through your footage like
there was like stuff of you flying
through and there's just a guy stuck
behind you like screaming no so that's
those are some of the side quests it's
more or less an escort mission but the
challenge is not escorting the person
the challenge is
uh bringing them to the point in town
that they want to be in and just knowing
what they're referring to but yeah like
you can use like an uber you pick up an
npc you're like all right we're going
and they just literally like float in
and out of frame
but we're going we don't need grass
right so dawn lookers slow shot you got
just a pan and it looks like cat's
flying it looks all cool for like a
while right slowly pans around this guy
just behind her screaming i'm glad you
got that because i definitely meant to
capture that the game does not take
itself too seriously no it doesn't it
doesn't good um yeah the little side
machines will take a topic seriously for
a moment but then it'll kind of bring it
around to this hyper-positive optimistic
thing but overall you gave it a glowing
review people should play it yeah i
think i really think people should it's
super unusual it definitely takes a lot
of getting used to but it is it is a
very fascinating experience and and
just joyful throughout cool so yeah that
is the uh gravity rush 2 review peter
brown gave it a 9 out of 10. that will
be on that is up on gamespot.com now if
you want to read the whole thing we have
a video review as well should be on
youtube or if you're watching this if
you're listening to this on itunes you
can go check it out at gamespot.com and
let us know what you think about the
game would you get the chance to play it
or let us know if you plan on picking it
up in the comments below
all right for some more uh negative news
if you're a scalebound fan
scalebound has got delayed no shitty
joke um scaly got canceled at least in
terms of uh you know like being released
from microsoft i guess there's no word
on whether it could ever happen again
well microsoft owns the ip so that won't
happen again probably not i mean what
they're
we'll get to this but they're courting
phantom dust around i mean yeah so
just as a primer uh if you don't know
scale bound at e3 2014 was shown off
it's a co-op action game uh platinum was
developing it uh people who made
bayonetta um you know metal gear rising
revenge and they're working on near auto
model right now which i want to get into
but
it's weird that at the microsoft e3 2014
press conference it was project spark
phantom dust remake crackdown 3 and
this game yep scale bound
project sparked release to little
fanfare phantom dust remake is now a
thing that's supposed to come out this
year but for a while it's kind of in
hiatus crackdown 3 no one knows what's
going on with that and now you have
scalebound which is cancelled
microsoft their statement uh it was
originally like a report by kotaku or a
rumor but then a bunch of people
confirmed it and whatnot uh microsoft
said after careful deliberation
microsoft studios has come to the
decision to end production for scale
bound we're working hard to deliver
amazing lineup of games to our fans this
year though including halo wars 2
crackdown 3 state of decay 2 sea of
thieves and other great experiences
sounds kind of like a defensive
statement like
people like
i am reading into it saying what is
going on with microsoft you know they
have the scorpio on the horizon in terms
of hardware but what's going on with
software i'm reading into it as
microsoft studios has decided we no
longer want to make japanese games but
we have a lot of exciting western games
to look forward to in the future um
like it's it's no secret that western
and eastern companies have you know
different styles of developing games and
we see a lot of games from japan get
delayed like that's a thing that happens
quite a bit scalebound itself has
has it been at least one official delay
before the cancellation something like
that 2016 and 2017 because of quote from
microsoft a crowded holiday release
schedule yeah like that's such that's
such bs but what did you so you heard
that or wasn't it part of the rumors
that right like the developers had gone
on this break because of development
crunch yeah the rumor was that it was
too strenuous so like the top developers
went on a break for a month and then
when they came back or shortly after
they came back it was decided that hey
uh we're gonna cancel this game but i
think if you look even a few months back
the president of platinumgames i believe
i'm getting his position correct and i'm
sorry i don't remember his name but he
left the company he left the company
after probably two years of it sort of
changing its mo right where it used to
be these one-off like great action games
and they started taking all this license
stuff that they were gonna make
uh
and is it that surprising to see him
leave and then see scalebound end up
cancelled like
i'm not that surprised by that yeah i
think that there might be a connection
not directly to that but
some sort of you know by proxy like yes
the problems that led to scale bounds
cancellation
you know that platinum is responsible
for not microsoft where the platinum is
perhaps that is you know part and parcel
for why this guy left and i really don't
know so don't take me for my word but it
just seems like
what a perfect storm you know back in
april of this year uh japanese game
industry site game business announced
that yeah president platinum games
tetsuya minami has stepped down yeah
it's just it's weird we're talking about
mass effect andromeda later and all the
studio departures and you know crises
that happened during the development of
that and who knows how that's going to
turn out march 21st the release date now
but
yeah you have to wonder between the
delay from 2016 and 2017 uh i personally
was not that impressed with the e3
2016 demo they showed um for those of
you watching right now
it's the uh it was that co-op uh fight
against that giant crab boss i mean it
looks impressive yeah in terms of scale
no pun intended it seemed you know
massive right like the scope of it
seemed pretty huge and the idea of co-op
seemed really cool too yeah it just
struck me as a co-op devil may cry or
something similar yeah but the execution
just didn't seem like at least in the
demo right it's like supposed to be this
big open world and it's like hey here's
a boss in an enclosed area and it's
going to be kind of a slow fight yeah
like oh that doesn't it doesn't ring
platinum to me that doesn't ring open
world you know co-op rpg
did anyone get a chance to play this had
they done any demos or no only behind
closed door stuff and i don't even think
with press
yeah so this is the question i wanted to
ask is what does this bode for microsoft
in terms of like first party titles uh
jacob tuff on twitter actually asked the
same thing with this being continue or
sorry he had a couple tweets
um
so
uh previous correction orion the blind
forest was also showed at 2003 2014 so
one of those games okay uh came to
fruition and i love that game um so yeah
jacob tuff said back in 2014 phil
spencer was saying how there will be
tons of new games for xbox one three
years later they're still coasting on
game announcements from 2013 2014 and in
that time
games have been canceled and multiple
studios closed lionhead fable legends uh
with this being a continuous trend how
worrying is this for the future of
microsoft first party offerings in the
long term i don't even know if in the
long term i mean we're talking again
talking about this in a later segment
what's our game predictions for this
year i would assume halo 6 will be
announced
um
gears of war 4 just came out gears war 5
will be a thing because that's what the
coalition under rod ferguson is working
on here we are stretching to come up
with like a handful of titles but we
also put an article up the other day and
i'm not playing a fanboy here i'm just
stating facts you know playstation 4
exclusives for 2017 there's like over 35
games in there yeah and you look through
that list and it's like yep sounds good
yep sounds good man i wonder what that
is like it all looks super promising
um
sony's also taken a lot of risks and
followed through on them right so i
think that it speaks to a different sort
of behavior and outlook for the two
companies um microsoft has made a bigger
push into the pc space not not huge not
like game changing but enough to maybe
indicate or signal that
they don't see the console business the
same way that sony does anymore right
for sony it is like a huge pillar for
their business for microsoft
i guess i don't know offhand but but
when you look at the sort of you know
the activity around it it doesn't seem
to be the thing that is like
representative of microsoft in
everyone's eyes what is for sony like
playstation is really i think yeah no i
mean like after oh sorry no no no yeah
so i i just think that they're they're
forking they're taking a different path
well it's weird because
back like mid-summer late summer when
the pro ps4 pro and the uh ps4 slim were
announced and everything and then you
know the scorpio we knew the scorpio was
gonna be essentially when it releases
this year um it felt like microsoft not
to just look at it in terms of
competition but it felt like microsoft
kind of had the upper hand in terms of
you know like public visibility at least
in terms of hardware again but yeah now
we're getting into the year and scorpios
on the horizon but like you just said we
don't have much else to just like hang
our hats on right scale bound however
it looked pretty cool and
slightly promising but i wasn't
particularly looking forward to it but
now that that's gone i mean even if you
just want to talk about platinum games
they released teenage mutant ninja
turtles mutants in manhattan which was
kind of a bust right um they also did
the um
well they have near automata coming up
and that's kind of the next upcoming
title they have two others
in the works right now or at least
announced grand blue fantasy project
relink
and lost order
but nir automata is the next upcoming
one which i played and i'm really
excited for it looks good and it feels
good i'm so excited i want to be excited
for lost order because as someone who
loves final fantasy tactics
matsu nassan and a few other people who
made final fantasy tactics are making
lost order under platinum it's like a
talk about another perfect storm like it
sounds so great but it's a mobile game
platinum also released
zero they did yeah so
what is going on i don't know but so
back to microsoft though right like they
face a huge uphill battle with scorpio
because at the beginning it was like all
about we're the most powerful right but
what does that actually equate to now
granted it's going to be more powerful
than ps4 pro like that seems to be the
way it's going to pan out
but look at what happened with the
reception for ps4 pro it kind of came
out people were excited for a minute and
then they realized like crap like maybe
it's not hard for developers but as a
player i'm realizing that this thing
gives me too many options and the games
across the board don't support every
option so the ps4 pro has been kind of
divisive and i think that's maybe set up
microsoft to have a bit of a challenge
when they release scorpio because is it
just going to be that same thing all
over again right yeah people who've been
watching from the sidelines with pro
like they might say well
i'm not going to make the same mistake
again or i've i've already seen other
people make this mistake and
so if they don't have
power being the thing that's going to
sell the console it has to be games yeah
it's just the same old games and they're
also on pc like
i know that's the thing like i mean i'm
excited for halo wars 2. but am i going
to play that on my xbox probably not
yeah because i mean it's an rts first of
all it makes more sense on pc but like
i don't know like especially like forza
horizon i got forza ryzen 3 not that
long ago and i played on my xbox a
little bit and i just switched to pc i
was like oh it looks better than this
and like with cross save and everything
like it'd be great to say you know the
xbox would make an awesome extension for
pc gaming
but i don't know that a lot of games
that really thrive on pc could you know
work on a console and there's already a
lot of crossover like when a game makes
sense it's multi-platform now and it's
on pc already so microsoft doesn't
really have
that advantage to look forward to or
even plan for the other two games they
mentioned state of decay 2 which i'm
excited for that'd be great i mean that
game sounds cool yeah like the first one
was great but it was pretty technically
flawed yeah so hopefully this one they
can iron out the issues with that but
it's not that massive of a game in terms
of just kind of you know peg your plan
on like a halo 6 or something which
again i'm i think that will be announced
this year and uh you know they need some
of those first party titles gears war
five i don't know one will actually see
anything on that for we're still on the
you know tail end of four's release uh
but they also mentioned sea of thieves
rares game right uh i've played it a few
times they only showed us bite size
elements it's that it's a first person
like mmo kind of cartoony
art style with pirates yeah and i'm i
don't see myself playing that for very
long yeah like a flag flagship title it
seems like a really cool idea but like i
feel like all the stuff they act out in
demos and trailers like i'll play online
and people are just gonna be jerks when
is that supposed to come out
i think it's
kind of soon
yeah because halo wars 2 is right around
the corner next year it's like next
month uh state of decay 2 i don't
believe
they've announced the actual specific
date sea of thieves will be just says
2017 but i think it's soonish
i don't know i don't think they should
be saying by now yeah this late into
development if it's if they're not
putting a date on this year
yeah i don't see it weren't there rumors
too that like something about fable like
they might try to bring back fable or
something like that like fable legends
was canceled but then they were saying
like maybe there's some way to revive it
in a different form but because like
there's been official movement and like
with even fable legends like i don't
think anyone was that bummed that that
got cancelled because that's not what
people wanted with a fable game so
i don't know like i think if they
relaunch fable into like an rpg like it
was originally intended i mean
originally made i think that could be
something that people would be
interested in but
i don't know basically as a crackdown
fan i would like crackdown 3 to kind of
see the light of day sometime this year
it sounds like in their statement
they're saying it will but who knows
maybe that'll be will that be as late as
an e3 announcement and then they'll say
hey it's the reason this fall or they do
something sooner
i hope they would do something sooner i
think it would benefit them so they
would have some sort of confidence going
into the late summer and fall releases
i'm sure that game would be a good
candidate to tie into scorpio because
one of the things about that game it's
actually not related to the console it's
related to their servers but that game
has like real-time destructibility in
incredible environments um
which if they were able to say hey look
what the look what this can do and we're
playing on scorpio even though it's
being run off you know off the cloud
yeah um i could see that as being the
right time for them to sort of be like
yeah and here's this game yeah i mean
it would benefit them i think to have
like it's not a brand new console but it
would still be like you know having
people like games to launch with the
scorpio it's a stable i mean consoles
are a statement and scorpio is a
statement it's just not like a a new one
it's a revised one yeah yes i mean for
all intents purposes right now xbox is
future with the xbox one it's sort of
cloudy but you know
hopefully in the coming months or the
coming weeks they actually
figure things out or show us that they
have figured things out or
i don't know remember when recore was
supposed to be great yeah
i keep it's a lot of promises and a lot
of hope but i don't know what about
quantum break oh no
stop stop talking about quantum break
peter no we shouldn't
i feel like i've already bad mouth
microsoft enough uh yeah whatever anyway
uh so yeah that is we talked about the
scale bound
cancellation for the platinum games they
have near automata coming up in a couple
months time uh but yeah so what do you
think about the xbox one's future let us
know uh whether you are a sony fanboy a
pc fanboy xbox fanboy i'm stoking the
flames and we need more comments on this
fanboy or a sega fanboy yeah uh let us
know in the comments below what you
think about the xbox one's future
all right
all right people hate when i do that um
cool but yeah that's a good segue into
this next segment um if you're just
joining if this is a breakout video on
youtube or anything we just talked about
scale bounds cancellation if you're
watching this live i apologize for being
redundant but we just wanted to talk
about the most disappointing cancelled
games ever or at least in the last you
know in recent memory um
i mean because between scale bound i
think another one recently was star wars
1313 which
you know you have amy henning up at uh
ea visceral who is working on a star
wars game and i think that's kind of
rising from the ashes of 1313 from my
understanding kind of like kind of like
it's a phoenix from him that's been a
while though right
was a long time ago it's it's it's
coming from 13 13 in the sense that like
overwatch came from titan yeah it's like
the studio kind of rebounding i would
say i don't know maybe that's a bad
comparison but 1313 looked great uh
maybe just because it was it looked more
like this mature star wars the demo they
showed at least an e3 demo correct
if it wasn't an e3 demo some big
convention stage and uh it was a third
person
shooter and you know based around uh
they said it was going to be like bounty
hunters right wasn't the 13 13 specific
i don't know i would need more like star
wars fans in here i love star wars we
all love star wars but like we need an
expert in here
don't speak for me i don't i don't love
you you don't like star wars all right
there we go stoking more flames uh but
yeah it just
never ended up coming to fruition they
were promising this gritty star wars
adventure which
i don't know most of the time star wars
can be pretty lighthearted in terms of
video games unless you're talking about
dark forces which is the best star wars
game ever made and i'll argue anybody
who disagrees
i don't know were you guys excited for
star wars 13 13 when you saw it first
announced
uh it looked nice
yeah but we didn't have anything to
really hang our hat on yeah i mean i
like star wars and gritty cool
storytelling yeah cliched new video game
yeah it looked like a cool idea yeah
what about battlefront 3
that i was really excited for because we
have battlefront now
but that game is boring it's not what i
wanted yeah that's not what i wanted
battlefront 3. uh i went back to play
that recently with dlc and yeah that
game is boring i don't like battlefront
that much it looks great and as a star
wars fan it's fun to be in that universe
for a little bit just the spectacle of
the thing and the bombast of these
massive like hoth battles even though
we've been to hoth
35 times before in video i've actually
never been to hoth before no in video
games okay this time of year it's awful
did you play the vr
part of the deal no i did not but rob
hanlery here says it's pretty awesome we
should play that it's out we've got it
it's x-wing centric one right yeah yeah
yeah uh i i know rob is saying that's
more worth playing than the uh the
scarif dlc like the rogue one based dlc
for star wars battlefront i'm putting
words in his mouth rob says a lot of
things though rob does a lot of things
he's in back right now uh yeah but we
won't
cut them
yeah cut to the back cam and see if
rob's pissed off if you can
there is
[Music]
i apologize i was listening on the
podcast that joke probably didn't land
but rob looked pretty pissed off uh but
yeah anyway moving on from that uh no
sorry star wars battlefront 3. that
looks really great i mean battlefront 2
was unreal between the space battles uh
the actual overall um conquest mode
galactic conquest that was awesome like
actually upgrading your army buying the
new uh perks buying the new units that's
fantastic and just like how you like i
mean conquer the galaxy you just move
from one point to the other and then
like you'll have a space battle here
like they could be taking back like
i don't know another planet or something
i don't know it's just this is a really
cool idea that was kind of a shame that
that just got cut yeah i mean
it essentially
seemed like what battlefront is now but
with the actual structure and mechanics
of earlier battlefront games like a
really good looking battlefront too for
intense purposes which is what everybody
in their right mind wants although i
don't think it would have looked as good
as ea's battlefront no i think they put
dice put way more uh effort into making
battlefront look good maybe because they
realize the gameplay didn't have much
substance to it uh anyway the most
disappointing one i can think of ever if
not just in recent memory is silent
hills yeah uh not just for guillermo del
toro's involvement but for obviously
hideo kojima's involvement norman
reedus's but also just because pt was
great uh for those who don't know
uh pt ended up you know was released
from um for what the number is but it
was a pseudonym for um kojima studios
and kojima productions and then
it was a playable teaser that ended up
if you completed it after you had
you know done enough to get through it
it was this uh
you know horror
video game based in this one house you
had found out that it was an
announcement for silent hills this
actually wasn't in the pt demo no this
was not this is not the pt this is part
of like a prototype before it right yeah
this looks almost like i don't know
allison wrote or something but this is
this is from the pt production just it
was not in the playable teaser it was
actually a really cool scene at the end
here i think yeah the playable teaser
was just essentially you crawling you
going through this one hallway over and
over and over again in the house there's
a favorite part stories of this holy
[ __ ] i don't remember seeing this yeah
so they actually this guy who's crawling
down the hallway right now people picked
a part pt demo and they found the
character model for this guy oh this is
the one you're talking about yeah yeah
but yeah i mean that's disappointing as
hell as a fan of guillermo del toro's
movies and a fan of most things kojima
has done
this is a huge blow and obviously this
was kind of the crux for the whole or at
least part of the big problem the whole
fallout with konami in kojima and of
course now with pt pulled from uh
playstation
store because konami said it was never
going to be released so there's no point
in having it we're not really going to
ever see something people list
playstation 4 is a pt installed for four
figures on ebay yeah they don't
necessarily say you accidentally deleted
it
yeah i did have you you've heard this
story before probably uh you know how
when you press options on an app on the
playstation menu
the menu comes up and it says there's
like close application delete i meant to
close the application and i deleted it
but the sinister part of your
subconscious was like
yeah
jay what do you mean don't phrase it
like that didn't you you know very well
you're just trying to push my buttons
you saw
he didn't see it happen he saw the like
pt not installed or like unavailable or
something he's like oh what happened
yeah it's still listed if you go to your
your your whatever like the games that
you own you can they'll still sit there
and it's like sorry won't download it
for yeah
mine's still there of course now mike's
gonna sneak into my room and delete oh
my god it's gonna be great isn't there a
way
or wasn't there a way a few months ago
that you could just get around and
potentially [ __ ] up your playstation
uh like you did it like a year ago you
could essentially like tap into like a
spoof server that had the data on there
you had to like go through i think a vpn
to like whatever
get the game sure um
yeah my ps4 you would understand my ps4
sucks
now it's only worth like 200 instead of
400. yeah here we are talking about how
sony's found through on promises sony
has nothing to do with this i'm just
being
hard-headed can you believe that they've
actually released last guardian i
believe that happened yeah
not really i haven't finished that game
yet neither why it's a different
conversation what's wrong with you guys
you mean what's wrong with me no i said
what the hell is wrong
okay give me silent hills and then you
finish that and i'll finish last
guardian what
i don't know i'm still pissed you had to
bring up the whole thing about deleting
silent hit pt
can we make that a section with a nude
lobby i just bring up you uh you just
push my buttons and i scream and i get
pissed off and you can't even host the
show anymore
i lost my place on this list all right
rainbow six patriots rainbow six siege
is a very good game i really like
playing that jake i know you do too
aaron samson here at uh gamespot plays
that a lot as well
talks about it a lot too it's a very
good shooter tactical shooter but when
rainbow six patriots was first announced
it was more uh story driven it was well
as opposed to not really story driven at
all for siege but
it looked pretty cool it was more about
you know domestic defense i guess and
then of course this demo not to spoil
this demo right now but what clip are we
showing i have no idea what this is
actually wrong yeah go to the part with
the bridge there's a part later on where
this civilian has bomb strapped to him
or her this is a great shooter i can
tell yeah his wife's square this just
looks like
heavy rain here we go this is what i was
hoping to see uh yeah this civilian has
bomb strapped to him so you end up
essentially
you know push bodies pushing the squishy
off the bridge in order to it looks like
it was like you know weighing the needs
of the few of us the money asking moral
questions about this preemptive defense
and this kind of special warfare and
whatnot it's pretty grim and it actually
kind of turned heads at the time because
of you know rainbow six has always been
this good guys versus bad guys a story
uh under tom clancy and everything uh
but this looks like it was actually kind
of hoping to tread new ground but it
never came to fruition ubisoft changed
direction and rainbow six siege was
really still a great game but kind of
disappointing because
rainbow six patriots looks like it might
be doing something looks like it might
be doing something interesting yeah i
mean as cool as i love the multiplayer
rainbow six siege i played a lot of it
when it came out but
the no campaign in there like no co-op
campaign especially coming off vegas one
and two where like co-op campaign that's
like i spent so much time doing that and
it was kind of a bummer that that got
cut and then you look at this and it
seems like they were in the works for
something like that yeah um in terms of
another game that
kind of
is
in a new form now it's prey too so
arcane studios under ralph cole antonio
is making prey just the remake
essentially and it looks great from all
for all intents purposes from what we
played uh obviously like harvey smith at
arcane headed up development on um
dishonored two and then ref colantonio
the people who worked on the duo who
worked on uh dishonored one ralph
calantonio is now doing uh heading up
prey and it looks great but part two
back in the day in uh 2009
development began it was announced in
2006.
developer 3d realms was supposed to be
working on it
our publisher
3d arms was going to publish it in the
developer human head studios did not
begin working until 2009 after the rice
for prey had transferred from 3d realms
to xenomax media the parent company
bethesda but then it [ __ ] just hit the
fan and pray two never came along did
you guys play pray one 2006 no i did you
did what'd you think of it it was super
weird i mean i remember it came out when
there weren't many other first-person
shooters on the 360 at that time or at
least not many sci-fi i think i was like
waiting for halo 3 or something like
that and it was fun like it was cool
with what it did
but i don't
like it i don't remember a lot of it i
remember it did a lot with like gravity
like you're like running upside down and
stuff like that um this i thought looked
much cooler because it looked more like
a han solo type like bounty hunting and
stuff like that like it seemed pretty
cool yeah so then the rights kind of uh
quietly transferred to arcane studios
but then bethesda formally canceled the
game in 2014 but lo and behold here we
are again and arcane is making prey
and essentially i'm actually not that
disappointed because i think it gives
arcane more leeway to do whatever they
want with it within that existing
universe and doing weird things you
could transform into like cups
that's what i've always wanted to do it
looks awesome i want to hit square to
kiss my wife and i want to turn into
cups
yeah
just fill yourself with coffee i don't
understand what's going on in this
footage right now it does look super
weird uh prey 2 is
yeah just kind of cease to exist and now
we have prey so again just like star
wars 1313 or titan
cancelled but kind of rising from the
ashes again phrase pete's
making fun of me for saying all the time
you're just so dramatic that's all yeah
another third-person shooter starcraft
ghost ghost starcraft ghost
third-person shooter following the
terran psychic espionage agent nova uh
this reminds me of commander conquer
renegade were you guys coming to conquer
fans yeah back in the day like when it
was like red alert two yeah it's one of
my favorite games did you ever play
renegade no they took command congrats
made it first person no
it was the first person yeah that was
okay
i played it wasn't that good it actually
was awful but it was cool that like a
strategy franchise uh being a big rts
fan it was weird to see it go into
another genre i love first person but
that was the case with
starcraft ghost
first person is a perspective
not a genre first person shooter oh okay
sorry sorry uh
jake were you pretty did you play do you
play a lot of starcraft or did you i
mean i played starcraft i didn't play a
lot of it i never got to like i just
played the story did you play a lot of
ghosts i played a lot of ghosts i
actually finished it and then i told
them they should probably cancel this
game because really not good yeah so
people can hate me they brought you in
as a consultant
no um i didn't play any of it actually
and i don't think anyone played
any of it but that game was delayed a
lot if i remember correctly and then
finally got cannon i remember that stung
quite a bit for a lot of people people
were really excited for that game yeah
because it was based around kind of
stealth and uh telekinesis and psychic
psychic powers and whatnot so it looks
like it was kind of doing you know a
twist on the original or traditional
third-person formula which other games
have done you're looking at like uh was
it vanquish am i thinking of a really
good third-person shooter and it was a
turn for blizzard as well to do
something different which people always
got excited about and they were really
successful for a while doing that yeah
they still are yeah talking about
overwatch
they do
really well when they branch into new uh
fields but yeah and then the last one i
want to touch on which i don't know
whether it
will strike a chord with people anymore
but lmno i remember was uh ea announced
it and it was in conjunction with steven
spielberg
they just sold it as this
story-driven adventure game with an
emotional arc i think honestly the only
reason people were excited for it was
that steven spielberg was attached to i
think it was late 2010 or 2011 that it
was shown so what what was hot for
spielberg around that what was he coming
off road to prediction war horse in 2011
did he do war horse yeah he did war
horse i don't not wrote the perdition
that was a while it was like 2004 wasn't
it i don't know
uh
who made that movie where the dinosaurs
come back to life
um guillermo del toro yes yeah um anyway
but
yeah lmno just figured i'd bring it up
because it's a big deal and got canceled
but again i don't know how much of that
was just based on the fact that steven
spielberg's attached to it why are you
trying to bury mega man legends three
i'm not gonna let you move on bringing
up mega man legends three if you want to
it's fine but mega man legends three was
a really poor cancellation because for
years people wanted this game keiji
nafuni was like i know i know i want to
do it too he was still at capcom he was
like all right capcom wants to make it
happen
outside of keiji inafune capcom was like
hey fans we want to hear what you want
this game to be so we're going to put
out a poll not enough people voted in
the poll and so when the game was
canceled they said not enough people
spoke up so we thought no one cared
that's awesome
thank you that's a great story i think
because it is really funny whoa
that's the most direct way to get like
use your feedback
let us know what you think if you want
this game to happen if they say how many
like responses they needed like what if
they just they needed 350 and they
didn't even get it i mean like i think
maybe the truth has actually come out to
be slightly different than that but that
was the the messaging from the
spokesperson at the time
so you guys didn't speak you guys
where were you did you vote
uh you didn't make enough email accounts
i was too many times as possible this is
what happened
trump i was working in a kitchen
you were working in a kitchen yes oh
this is pretty yeah this is how what
when was this oh whoa when was it 2010
maybe 2011 was when it was canceled but
2010 was when they were like all right
this is the thing and like
before the 3ds came out they're like oh
we're gonna put out demos soon so you
guys can play the game like that never
even happened that would have been a
good cautionary tale for hillary clinton
to use in her campaign this is what
happens when you don't vote yeah kj
fooney should have been her advisor
did you like mega man legends and one
and two
no
why is this disappointing to you though
not disappointing to me disappointing to
a lot of people oh come on i like that
those games exist but it doesn't
like the volcanoes exist but
i'm not gonna go
play one
volcanoes don't get canceled either
it's a good point they're always ready
to go mega man legend of three is just
waiting to erupt at some point we'll see
it again remark my words microsoft is
gonna yeah blow us all out of the water
yeah with the launch bundle for the
scorpio with mega man legends three this
is kind of out of left field but do you
do you remember i think it was called
like something las vegas and you just
like walked around las vegas jean luc
actually brought it up like about a
couple weeks ago and i was like i forgot
about this game and it was just like you
walk around las vegas and you gamble and
it got cancelled
i don't remember what it was called i
don't remember what it was like we were
going to end on a high note jake yeah
well john luke before we go
what is this game called john luke's in
the back right now vegas baby i think
that was
what it's called was it john luke's game
this is this is vegas it's the most
literal thing ever that's just like
someone driving through the desert
that's like what city is this like oh
this is vegas
that's the game that's the key what do
people do here you're doing this
60 bucks to come across this random city
in the middle of a desert sick
put 12 on black and then i'll
see you at the bar later
gambling joke you guys never i don't
gamble i don't like vegas i've never
been to vegas but i don't like it i
wouldn't want to play a game yeah you
stand up oh here's the website
try clearing your cookies this has gone
on long enough it's depressing for a
number of reasons namely so because
scalebound's canceled for people who are
looking forward to that and like
platinum games like myself it is
disappointed so
let's hope no other games get canceled
let's hope crackdown 3 releases let's
hope
state of decay 2 comes to fruition uh in
the meantime let us know what your most
disappointing canceled game is or was
regardless of how long ago it was please
don't talk to me about megan the man
legends three i've heard enough about it
leave your thoughts in the comments
below
jesus um
we didn't even talk about fez a game
that was canceled over a twitter
argument oh yeah that that's a whole
because two can of worms uh
a game that we hope does not get delayed
again mass effect andromeda
what's going on with this game scary
yeah
what do you guys think jake you don't
you didn't seem optimistic today sorry
uh really quick just primer yeah aaron
flynn studio manager at bioshock
bioware edmonton said uh march 21st
release date 2016 of this year mass
effect andromeda is coming
and that is the release date as of now
but we are wondering what is going to
happen with that because
all throughout the development process
of this game there's been studio
departures there has been you know like
rumors about development crunch getting
to people much like it sounds like was
the case with scalebound or any game
nowadays it seems like mega man legends
theory
and now we're kind of wondering what is
going on mass effect andromeda is it
being rushed i think a lot of footage
we've seen has not really comforted us
ah a lot of footage
sorry sorry some footage little footage
some of the little footage we've seen
the fact that there is only a little
footage the fact that we have barely
seen gameplay
uh is worrying and it's like two months
away what's going on with this jake are
you pretty worried
i'm i'm kind of worried
i like
they've had a lot of time to work on
this game they've worked on it for five
years now at least that's what they said
recently
so like
is this game being rushed like
maybe not like maybe they could hit
march i don't think they will though
because like what you were saying how
like a lot of people have left a lot of
people are like
dealing with stress and like crunch time
i think this game has changed a lot over
the last couple years and now they've
kind of arrived on their idea and
they're like all right we need to like
get this done
so i'm i think it's going to get delayed
you think it's going to get delayed i
think it's going to get delayed i hope
it doesn't like i don't want to be that
one like
everyone like if it gets late everyone's
like oh you're the one like
i don't want to be that guy i don't want
to be that guy but i think it's going to
be delayed and like like you were saying
too we haven't seen much gameplay like
we have finally seen gameplay and what
we've seen looks pretty mediocre
no come on me yeah mediocre okay you
know what they haven't shown jake they
haven't done any of the dialogue stuff
they they showed a little bit of it and
it wasn't that good right okay like i
mean it was what's another word for not
that good it was it was mediocre
it was a huge improvement over uh like
mass effect 3 mass effect 2 but
i mean i've i've played the witcher a
lot and
like looking at like the dialogue that
you go through in the witcher which even
then it's still kind of like
it's still kind of like cheesy at times
and like kind of like technical there's
like little technical issues but then
with this it looked worse than that and
it's just kind of like
i don't well it was like i don't know at
e3 when they showed off some stuff
people were criticizing the quality of
the animations and they were like oh
well they're not done yet and it's like
but but wait a minute this is your time
to finally show the game you're showing
something that's not done yeah what the
heck if you extrapolate that to the
bigger picture what does that mean that
means everything is probably problematic
like i think if it gets delayed that's a
good thing like i do too
rushing out a game if you've got a great
idea take the time to finish it that's
what we're hoping but yeah the whole
cause for concern the last year or so
especially when we interviewed aaron
flynn
either the day of or the day before they
showed that footage e3 this year
they're saying uh there were rumors
circulating that they had to strip a lot
of features because they were trying to
do too much initially and then ea gave
them this hard deadline so who knows how
long
uh bioware has known it was march 21st i
wonder if ea told them that like last
year or something amid all these rumors
of a departure one i'm sure they did but
aaron flynn said oh i didn't hear about
those rumors and whatnot it's a very
misdirection but i'm gonna level with
you mike you're right this game is in
horrible trouble
why else would their major people leave
what is going on with this maybe you
know they always say no we just the
game's in good shape everybody who left
of course they had that statement saying
this game is in great shape
why why show us this person's scanning a
room this is uh
oh they're bringing the makeup so who
cares
it's a car i don't mean to [ __ ] on this
game no i don't looking for it i don't
want to write that's just it you hope
it's good you're looking forward to the
chance that it's good but like i think
in the past mass effect games you could
watch some of the stuff they were
showing and say this game looks great
with this all you can say is i hope this
is great so yeah i mean and i think
that's what it comes down to like this
like the the
like not the multiplayer the gameplay i
think the combat looks pretty good it's
like a watered-down vanquish though
it doesn't i mean it it looks like an
improved okay relatively compared to
mass effect 3 i mean yeah okay it's i i
don't think it's gonna be
incredible but that's never the point i
mean i feel like i shouldn't even say
it's not the point because it is to have
a good game but like
the the gameplay wasn't what made the
game great right in my opinion yeah um
but yeah i mean
like what you were just saying like
seeing mass effect 3 sing mass effect 2
seeing mass effect 1 i was blown away
and then i see this and i was hoping to
get that same feeling
and i was like all right well
i'll probably play it and i hope i like
it
i hope it's good right like i'm not
trying to be a curmudgeon here it's just
like really telling this late in the
game to see just this amount yeah no
one's played it yet either right i mean
like look there's a similar problem with
doom where we didn't see a lot of that
game aside from multiplayer up until
launch and then it was like you know day
of release date review copies everyone
was nervous and holy [ __ ] that game
ended up being amazing that might be the
case here it totally could be but like
in the meantime what do we have to
really go on other than our hopes
i mean even what they showed at e3 it
wasn't just that it looked bad it wasn't
i there was no reason to even show it
was just a teaser still yeah and that
was what
six months ago seven months ago
i feel like they should be
they should be more on target by this
point because you know they said their
objective with it has to make a more
explorable kind of more openly seamless
world which is what i want to i think
what a lot of people want to see like
how how does the the tempest get from
area to area like because they confirmed
you won't actually be flying the ship
but if it's supposed to be seamless then
like how is it seamless you just like
walk in your ship and walk around while
it flies there for you
i don't know yeah i mean
you don't necessarily always want to
just hope a video game gets delayed but
i wouldn't be too surprised if it
happened i think you should hope a video
game gets delayed yeah if you're if you
want the game to be good when you
finally buy it and play it then
hopefully hopefully it gets delayed
unless it's because the team took a
break and came back and people said that
it wasn't worth pursuing like scalebound
or whatever supposedly happened yeah i
just hope it's not like dragon age
inquisition in space because i know a
lot of people like that game but that
game is born a lot of people don't like
that game good boring
yeah i was not a fan of that game and
like almost looking at some of those
wide areas like i kind of got that
dragon age inquisition vibe and i'm like
no please don't do this please don't do
this
yeah
i don't know so you think it's gonna get
delayed jake
i think it's gonna get delayed i hope it
gets delayed um but i'm still very
optimistic about it despite what i said
i i'm optimistic i think it's going to
be good okay yeah i don't think it's
going to be
fantastic i don't think it's going to be
like the next witcher 3 for me
but i think i'm going to enjoy it i
would be much less worried if the past
year and a half two years wasn't just
news about the studio people huge people
departing the studio and leaving and
like
clearly the studio was stressed out in
the you know
trying to figure out what to do with
this franchise you know it's not gonna
be really connected to the first trilogy
too much you know aside from the name
and uh you know your characters are new
and everything it's a new galaxy so it's
not really connected at all but
you know i'm worried that maybe the
weight of the project their you know
grasp it's exceeded their reach or the
other way around grasp exceeded their
reach one on both yeah i guess so maybe
their reach and their grasp are too
short anyway
let us know what you think about mass
effect andromeda are you excited for it
do you think it'll be good
uh based on the gameplay we've seen so
far are you worried about it do you
think that bioware will pull through and
release a fantastic game let us know in
the comments below
all right last segment
predictions for 2017 we've already
touched on a bunch of these
uh between new games coming out this
year and delays cancellations hardware
can switch into scorpio
uh potentially a new nintendo classic
console re-release uh we want to get
into what we think is going to happen
this year we have another companion
article publishing uh today later today
uh basically different editors takes on
what they think will happen this year
but i wanted to get
your guys thoughts on what we can
foresee in the future in 2017. uh i'll
start though
i think in terms of software if you see
halo 6 they're going to announce that
microsoft needs to i think uh eddie
mccoo our news editor said he predicts
that there will be split screen this
time around halo 5 guardians did not
have it much to the ire of long-time
halo fans like myself who you know love
playing four-player split-screen of
those games uh eddie mccoo thinks
they'll have it this time do you think
it'll come out in fall too
uh yeah i think it'll release in october
october 23rd
um and then destiny 2 i think will be
shown this year but i don't think we're
not going to see it might be a teaser
might be a trailer probably e3 i
wouldn't be surprised to see destiny 2.
you guys agree
yeah yeah it's about time yeah i think
so i think destiny the destiny trains
finally whatever steam it had to begin
with it's finally just running out of it
the expansions taken king you know rise
of iron i was not impressed with taking
king revamp the game enough and then
added some interesting end game elements
but i don't know between
those and the dark below i was not
overall that impressed with the the long
run of this game the more i played it
but there are a lot of fans of it and i
know people still play it eric tay still
plays everyone's while i don't know if
he has recently
but i think destiny 2 would be the shot
in the arm that bungie needs right now
and a lot of destiny fans need yeah to
say the least and bring it to pc
yeah do it
that was that would be pretty sweet
that'd be pretty sweet i like it do you
like destiny do you care too much for
testing i want to like destiny i really
like fantasy star online back in the day
and destiny always kind of reminded me
of that a little bit yeah
you know obviously it's first person but
um yeah i just uh
i couldn't get into it
yeah if you're watching our live show uh
we just
said a few of us think mass effect
andromeda might get delayed again jake
that's one of your predictions though
for those just joining us on youtube why
do you think mass effect and drama is
going to get delayed just because
everything we've talked about
about a year of people leaving the
studio coming back to it leaving uh did
i put that down
yeah on the i did put that down on the
dock that i think mass effect can get
delayed yeah okay yeah you did well yeah
i know i just said it but like for the
running order i think i wouldn't be
crazy surprised if it did march 21st is
close though that's two months away
let's hope they yeah don't pull the last
minute pull the rug out under her feet
here's the other thing
i think i believe i heard someone
talking about this on a podcast
so but could you have pre-ordered the
game beforehand i feel like pre-orders
for that just opened like right now
from andromeda yeah i know that they've
finally announced a release date oh i
don't know like probably did they should
probably have opened up or released the
date a lot longer than three months
before the game came out uh yeah i mean
that was because
i think it was like a bioware blog thing
aaron flynn tweeted it saying hey here's
a release date for you wondering
uh oh by the way i guess you can't
pre-order it now you can
so
super deluxe edition deluxe edition does
it come with the the mako thing
i think so yeah
man so mass effect 3 [ __ ] mass effect
andromeda mass effect 3 i like mass
effects 3 a lot whatever people say mass
effect andromeda kind of has an
uncertain feature right now let's let's
hope it's fantastic we'll be hopeful for
that um anyway p what about a super
nintendo classic yes it would make sense
they should do it they re-upped like the
patent for the controller or something
yes that's the deal some people are
speculating that might have something to
do with the super nintendo uh other
people are speculating in smaller
circles that there's a company called
8-bit do or 8-bit doe they do a lot of
really great retro themes or related
products one of them being a wireless
bluetooth controller that looks exactly
like the super nintendo controller and
is actually really good
um but anyway i think it's more likely
we're going to see the super nintendo
classic the nes classic
yeah i like the well the nes classic you
just had that like trouble with having
enough units for everybody yeah they
still have that trouble they still do
they still do ongoing yeah i couldn't
probably couldn't get one if i wanted to
yeah who do you think you are no i'm not
peter brown nes expert
you just have them stashed away in your
house and yourself i think he is
i don't know i don't think that's me
uh i'm gonna i'm gonna hoard sne super
nintendo classics and i'm gonna i'm
gonna not let you have this that's your
long-term investment plan one of them
yeah
uh that'd be awesome i would love to
play super metroid zombies ain't my
neighbors i'd love to play all those
games again what i would prefer and i'll
make this my prediction is that nintendo
is that nintendo actually takes the
virtual console seriously again
and is able to unify their accounts
online so people don't have to buy games
like the ones you just mentioned a third
time if they pick up a switch they can
just use their account and download it
and play it
uh that would be rad
because i don't even think they need a
super nintendo classic but again there's
people who won't buy the switch right so
or they won't buy the wii u so they can
use virtual console it's perfect for
them
do you see much happening with virtual
reality this year in terms of do you
think it'll keep going with its momentum
i mean sales weren't great last year but
i think last year you know more and more
titles came out that showed developers
have taken it seriously and maybe we
should too developers are taking it
seriously
um and i think consumers are to a degree
but i think it's more out of curiosity
in the fact that it's affordable and it
does something worth being excited about
but in terms of it really taking off
um maybe i'm just not doing my job right
but i can't think of a single vr game on
the horizon
that i'm that i'm excited about
resident 7 is the first one that comes
to mind but that's like a couple weeks
away but you can also play it and i'm
not excited about that like that's
that's cool for people who own a
playstation vr and i'm excited about the
game itself but the vr portion of that
is not like a good sign that oh vr is
here and doing something special it's
vr is a means to experience you know
traditional media okay fine we've done
that move beyond that show us what
virtual reality really can do um and i
think that there's a lot of places that
are still spinning their wheels trying
to you know rev that stuff up and get it
ready or even just experimenting with
what works and what doesn't sure um so i
think we'll see a lot of hardware
incremental improvements i think we'll
see some cost go down it's already gone
down on the pc front like you can get
much more affordable hardware to play vr
games on including playstation so i
think we'll see more of that before we
see more you know big games that really
do say
vr is amazing it's here this is why yeah
in terms of other predictions any others
i'm i'm i think crackdown 3 will release
with or around the scorpio sounds about
right so they would have to announce
that like any day now i feel like
scorpio is what
did close-ish even say no they say like
2017. yeah the year itself yeah so so
that'll be
it could be fall
yeah if it was fall cracked three i
would definitely say it's gonna i would
hope crackdown three is definitely gonna
be a release day for that yeah i don't
know any other predictions crystal balls
oh i have one 17 yeah i think we're
going to see cyberpunk 2077 for the
first time
when was that trailer i think 2013.
witcher 3 fan yeah and at the end of the
trailer they said it's ready when it's
ready or it'll be ready when it's ready
and i think
they're just about ready to start
showing things off yeah i don't think
we'll see a lot i don't think we'll see
gameplay
maybe we'll see gameplay but i think
we'll definitely get another trailer at
e3 or something like that
cd projekt red
uh do you think they'll just keep going
like a massive open world like the
witcher 3 with this because i don't know
much about the cyberpunk property i mean
i know generally like what they're going
for i mean
i we we don't really know anything like
we've heard like like they hired like
vehicle like people to work on like
vehicle i don't know if that's called
vehicle developers no
um but people hired a guy who can make
cars
um guy comes in with a wrench so i mean
it sounds like it's gonna be another big
open world rpg but i have a feeling
it'll be more like third person like
uh like shooter combat rather um but we
don't know anything about that and i
think
i think they're going to be showing
something off they were working on it
when i was there yeah um didn't you yeah
you didn't i just like warsaw right yeah
i just like walked through the offices
and they're like here everyone's hard at
work on cyberpunk don't ask about
cyberpunk
just ask about gwent yeah yeah
it's good it's not cyberpunk though
um
yeah but yeah now now's the time and
also you're gonna get a hot thumbnail
for this breakout too because not don't
use that thumbnail but
well i mean now that all the expansions
are out for the witcher 3 now and like
uh with um yeah i mean they're in line
they are done with
like because they were
like the people were asking if they were
gonna like upgrade the witcher 3 4
playstation 4 pro and they said no we're
not working on the witcher 3 anymore
because we want to focus all on
cyberpunk
and gwent i mean gwent is a very small
team i think they said there was like 12
people or something like that and
they've been beefing up their team quite
a bit
so
this and it's got to be soon cyberpunk
will be the first game that's not a
witcher game from the end for them yeah
yeah so
i have
all the faith in the world in cd projekt
red especially if they're kind of
sticking to that you know like you just
said open world structure that they did
so well with these uh
you know emergent storylines and kind of
player driven choice that the witcher 3
was great for so yeah here's hoping that
cyberpunk 27 does happen any other
predictions i think if it comes out this
year within the year still after the
fact
metal gear survive will be a free game
on playstation plus is it not already a
free game
would you pay for it if it wasn't i
completely forgot about that game until
right now thanks peter
you guys are welcome there you go so if
you forgot about metal gear survive
there's your peter there's your reminder
follow peter brown on twitter if you
want a daily reminder he's going to keep
telling everybody about metal gear
survive from now on uh but yeah anyway
let us know what you think about 2017
what you think is going to happen any
games you think are going to get delayed
cancelled moved around shuffled into the
mix shuffle back out of the mix let us
know your thoughts in the comments below
and that's our show today
there's again our first episode of the
season we are kind of making changes
next week again we're not going to be
airing on tuesday next week we're going
to be airing on wednesday at uh 11am for
those of you who join us regularly on
twitch or youtube or gamespot's live
streaming service you will see us
wednesday again we want to get the
audience more involved we want you
to send in input for the show sending
questions about the games now that you
get the chance to play them before you
watch the lobby on tuesdays send in
concerns about mega man legends 3. send
in fan art send in fan art of mike
send in fan art of peter brown no we
will show a hearty and we will show it
on the show yes
sure and uh any ideas you have for
segments if you want uh us to talk about
more about certain games more about you
know like just certain trends we will
kind of discuss them and uh again we
want your input let us know what you
think about the new studio change that
we do next week
we want to involve the audience because
we really appreciate you guys coming to
hang out with us every week and uh yeah
let's here's hoping that that goes
according to the plan uh thank you to
jean-luc
rob handler in the back mary kish is
back there somewhere too i think uh
let's give them a wave can you guys get
thrown up on screen quick
yeah you could do it there you go john
luke rob handler rob's busy texting he
has no idea what he's doing
and there is a gravity rush 2 stream
going on today pete is that you and mary
yeah me and murray all right mary kish
peter brown i'm going to be streaming
gravity rush 2 here on gamespot.com on
twitch on youtube go join them check it
out peter gave it a 9 out of 10. sounds
like a great game i'm gonna go play it
and thank you so much for joining us
today we will see you next week in our
new studio at a new time wednesday at 11
a.m pacific
uh later mary said to you but uh
when it goes in just
you